[MUSIC PLAYING]
LESLEY KATZEN: Welcome, Michele.
MICHELE FILGATE:
Thank you, Lesley.
LESLEY KATZEN: You're welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
So I want to say
congratulations.
MICHELE FILGATE: Thanks.
LESLEY KATZEN: This
is a phenomenal book.
I didn't know really
what to expect.
I had read your
Longreads essay, and I
had gotten a couple of
stories into the anthology,
and I am just completely floored
by how the number of writers
you have, how talented they are.
Writers that I hadn't known who
they were but then looked them
up afterwards and realized
how well-known they were.
And I thought it was
a very powerful book.
MICHELE FILGATE: Thank you.
LESLEY KATZEN: You're welcome.
Let me get my questions out.
So tell me a little
bit about your process.
I know that you are a
writer and an editor
and when the Longreads
essay came out,
tell me about what happened
in getting the book deal
and what you did to choose
the writers that you chose,
how you approached
them in that process.
MICHELE FILGATE: Sure.
So a little bit of
background first
is that the essay that
inspired this anthology
is way over a decade
in the making.
I started writing it when
I was an undergraduate.
And when I first
started writing it,
it was an essay about my
stepfather being abusive.
And it took me many years
to realize that actually
what this essay was about was
about a longing for a better
relationship with my
mother and the fracture
that this abuse caused
in our relationship.
So when the essay
was published--
it came out in October of 2017,
right when the MeToo movement
really took off--
and so many people
responded to my essay
but also to the
title of the essay,
"What My Mother And
I Don't Talk About."
I kept hearing from so
many people who said,
I have my own story of what I
can't talk about with my mom.
And so it was really
important to me
when I was putting
this anthology together
to have a diversity of not just
writers but different types
of relationships between
mothers and children.
So it's not just mothers
and daughters in this book.
There are mothers and sons also.
And some of the
people who are writing
are writing about mothers
who are no longer alive.
Some people are
estranged from their mom.
Some people are really
close with their mothers.
So we have a wide swath
here of representation.
And I reached out
to a lot of writers
that I admire to see if
they were brave enough
to write about what they can't
talk about with their moms.
And the result is
this book, which
has some of my favorite writers
in it like Alexander Chee, who
is a well-known novelist and
also his essay collection
that came out last year was
one of the biggest of the year.
He was featured in
"Time" magazine.
That essay collection
is called "How
To Write An
Autobiographical Novel."
He wrote a fantastic
essay about being sexually
abused as a choirboy and
not telling his mother
because he wanted to protect
her and the silence that that
caused.
But then there's
some funny pieces
in here too, like Cathi
Hanauer, who actually
is the editor of a mega
bestseller anthology called
"The Bitch In The House."
And she wrote about her father
being like really domineering
and how she could never have
a conversation with her mom
without her dad chiming
in all the time.
So that one is a
very humorous piece.
So we've got a wide
range of things.
And it was important to me to
get as many different writers
and stories in here
as possible and not
have it just be
a depressing book
but have some uplifting
essays as well.
LESLEY KATZEN: I think
that's one of the things,
as I go from essay to
essay, I feel like laughing
and then the next
one I'm gasping,
like, those two especially.
I think that I see a
lot of mother figures
reflected in a lot of
different types of mothers
in these books.
And I related to those
two essays specifically.
Yeah.
Oh, speaking of Alexander
Chee, so a lot of that essay
has to do with how he prepared
his mother for writing
the book.
And I'm wondering, did you
talk to your mother at all
before the Longreads
essay was published?
MICHELE FILGATE: No.
LESLEY KATZEN: So tell me
a little bit about that.
MICHELE FILGATE: Yeah.
So I know some writers who
will not publish anything
without telling the person that
they're writing about first
or waiting until
the person is dead.
And I completely respect that.
In my case, I knew that
my mother would not
be happy with this essay.
And I didn't want to
feel further silenced.
I felt like this was an
important story to tell,
that it was a story that
could help a lot of people.
So my mother found out after the
fact, after the essay was out,
and after I got the book deal.
And so that's really hard.
It's been very complicated.
And I'm hoping we'll be able
to talk about it at some point.
But it's been extremely
difficult. So it's sad.
LESLEY KATZEN: Yeah.
I mean, all of these
stories I think
are incredibly brave to tell.
I mean, there's
a reason why it's
called "Fifteen Writers
Breaking The Silence."
MICHELE FILGATE: Yes.
Yeah.
LESLEY KATZEN: Yeah.
So you also
mentioned that MeToo.
So this happened at
the same time as MeToo
or was this what compelled you
to actually write it down and--
MICHELE FILGATE: No.
So I was working on the
essay for well over a decade.
And then it just happened that
my editor at Longreads, Sari
Botton had accepted the essay,
I think, in September of 2017.
And then the Weinstein story
broke, and when that broke,
she was like we're moving
this up, because originally it
wasn't going to come
out until Thanksgiving.
And instead, it
came out that week.
So it was really published
during a crucial moment
when people were finally ready
to break silences about things.
But there's all
kinds of silences
that are broken in this book.
Like I said, it's
not just abuse.
One of my favorite piece--
I mean, they're all my
favorite, but I really
love this piece that
Lesley Jamison wrote
that I close the book with,
because it's such a nice note
to end on.
It's about how she's
so close to her mother,
and she wanted to understand
who her mother was
before she became her mom.
I think a lot of
us try to imagine
what our mom was like
before she became the mother
figure, right?
And it's hard to
imagine her without us.
And she reads an
unpublished manuscript
that her mother's first husband
wrote based on their marriage.
LESLEY KATZEN: Oh, boy.
MICHELE FILGATE: So that is
a really interesting essay.
LESLEY KATZEN: One of the
things that I had kind of noted
to myself was that despite there
are some really sad stories
here, but overall, I think it
paints a really sympathetic
view of mothers.
And it does seem like
all of the writers do--
I'm trying to think if there
are any-- there are probably
some exceptions,
but do kind of take
a sympathetic view
of their own mothers
and cut them a lot of
slack in the things
that they lacked in growing up.
MICHELE FILGATE: Yes.
LESLEY KATZEN: OK.
I've got some Oprah-y
questions here for you.
MICHELE FILGATE: Go ahead.
LESLEY KATZEN: OK?
MICHELE FILGATE: Yeah.
LESLEY KATZEN: OK.
So you say that mothers are
idealized as protectors.
In compiling all of these
stories and reading all of them
and doing all this
exploration, do
you think it's fair
to idealize mothers?
MICHELE FILGATE: I don't.
In fact, the "Los Angeles
Times" review of this book
talks about how this is a
book about allowing mothers
to be imperfect.
And I think that we--
I talk about this in the
introduction to the book.
But I think that we try to--
no one can check all the boxes
as the perfect mom, right?
Mothers are humans too.
And this book is
an attempt to show
that by mythologizing them,
that can be dangerous--
false mythologies around them.
So I think this is
a way of new stories
to look at moms in the light
of mothers can be complicated,
just like any human being.
And taking them
off that pedestal
and talking about
them as a human being.
LESLEY KATZEN: Yeah.
I mean, I always say I
recently became a mother.
It's been about five years now.
And it's just not fair, man.
I tell you.
You can't be everything
all of the time.
And as everybody
will tell you, it's
like you're going to end
up doing something that
is going to make your daughter
or son write an essay about you
at some point, I
think, in your life.
MICHELE FILGATE: Exactly.
LESLEY KATZEN: I mean, you know.
Why do you think, in
your essay specifically,
there are a couple of
instances that you talk
about your mother's lack of
compassion or understanding
of you, yet you have a
teacher who reaches out
to you who understands
what you're going through
and seems sympathetic
or you have,
I think, it was an
ambulance driver,
who kind of are able to protect
you and give you the comfort
that you need.
Why do you think it was
so hard for your mother
to give you those things and
so much easier for a stranger?
MICHELE FILGATE:
I think because--
I think it comes down to denial.
I think abuse causes
denial in relationships.
And I think for my mother to
admit that her husband was
abusive to me, it
would shatter what
her view is of her marriage
and of her home and her family.
And so I think
that's why I'm always
kind of seeking out mother
figures all around me, right?
Like, anyone who can be
nurturing or maternal.
And it's not to say that my
mom hasn't been maternal.
There are parts of her
that are wonderful,
and I talk a lot in the
book about her cooking
and how that's
something that makes
me feel really close to her.
But again, getting back to
that idea of our mothers
can't check all the
boxes, you know,
some mothers can't provide
that nurturing that we need.
And so we also need to kind
of learn to mother ourselves.
And that's something that I've
been thinking about a lot,
in not just editing this book
but talking about the book
and in my own life.
LESLEY KATZEN: Yeah.
I feel like I've heard that
a lot recently too, like,
learn to mother yourself or
especially I know that Mother's
Day, which is coming up--
MICHELE FILGATE: Yep.
LESLEY KATZEN: --pretty
impression on the book,
but I hear that a
lot for people who
are estranged of their
mothers, that they take the day
to kind of be the mother to
themselves that they never had.
MICHELE FILGATE: Yes.
LESLEY KATZEN: It's easy to--
yeah.
It's easy to stay bitter, but I
think that just if you have a--
OK, obviously, not all the
people in the anthology
have a strained relationship
with their mother,
but I think at some
point you do have
to give yourself what you need.
MICHELE FILGATE: Yes.
Absolutely.
And speaking of
Mother's Day, I think
the commercialization
of that holiday
makes it really hard for people,
because we're kind of inundated
on social media on that day with
tributes to people's mothers.
And like anything
on social media,
it's a curated experience.
So you don't see what
the complications
are in the relationship
that person
might have with their mom.
And those of us who
have felt unmothered
or who have never had our mother
around or who are estranged,
it's such a hard day.
Or people who have
lost their mother,
their mother passed
away, and there
are some people in this
book who write about that.
That day, Mother's
Day in particular,
can just be so
difficult. So I think
this is actually the
perfect book to read around
Mother's Day for self-care.
LESLEY KATZEN: It definitely
brought a lot of these feelings
to process a couple of weeks
before as I was reading it.
OK.
So I've heard this--
I think it was the NPR
review of this book--
and I wanted to hear
your take on it.
This is kind of like,
but why are mothers
so different than fathers?
Why not things my father
and I don't talk about?
I kind of know the
answer here, but I
want to hear your response.
MICHELE FILGATE: I
think it's because,
for most of us, obviously
not every mother--
I'm talking about
the bio mothers,
for our biological mothers,
we grow inside of them, right?
And so there's a body--
there's a corporeal attachment
there that you can't deny.
And I think that that makes
it so much more complicated.
I don't know.
Obviously, people
have plenty of stories
to tell about their
relationships with their dads
too.
And I could see that as
a whole other anthology,
although I'm very
close with my father.
But I think that
for mothers, there's
just something primal there.
There's something that--
like, we're always--
I talk about this in my essay.
The very beginning of
my essay is our mothers
are our first homes.
And that's why
we're always trying
to return to them to have
a place where we belong
or where we fit.
And I think that's so true.
And if we no longer fit
there, what does that mean?
Right?
So there's just--
it's more intense,
the mother-child relationship
than the father-child
in some ways,
although I know plenty
of people who have had intense
relationships with their dads
too.
LESLEY KATZEN: Yeah.
That really struck me too.
It's like, your first home
and your first relationship
is with your mother.
MICHELE FILGATE: Yes.
LESLEY KATZEN: I mean, or
with your biological mother.
Yeah.
It's kind of a trip
just to think about.
Michele, Melissa Febos--
I almost said Michele Febos--
but I love her.
And I'm glad--
I loved her essay so much.
She kind of got a little
bit to Greek mythology
in the relationship between
Demeter and Persephone.
MICHELE FILGATE: Yes.
LESLEY KATZEN: I loved that.
So she says that
all children are
built to be loved but
not all parents need it.
And you've spoken to her,
I think, about the essay,
but I think you
also did recently
talk with her on this book.
So maybe y0ou have
some insight in it.
Do you think that she
equates protection with love?
Her essays a lot
about her mother
bailing her out of things or
protecting her from the world.
MICHELE FILGATE: Yes.
Yeah.
I think so.
I mean, I'm curious to
hear what you think.
Do you think she protects?
She equates that?
LESLEY KATZEN: Yeah, I think.
I think that's probably
why I asked you.
MICHELE FILGATE: Yeah.
I mean, that essay in particular
is really interesting because,
like you said, it
looks at mythology
as a prism of a way to describe
her close-knit relationship
with her psychotherapist mother.
So it's already pretty
powerful that her own mom
is a psychotherapist.
But yeah, I think in that
essay, Melissa really
makes herself very
vulnerable on the page,
because she talks about when she
was going through some really
difficult times in her life.
And she kind of puts it
all out there, right?
And yeah, I do think that
protection in some ways,
but also you have to
kind of learn how to--
I think there's like a
duality there, right?
Because she also
was feeling like she
had to protect her
mom in some ways.
So it kind of--
I think there's a duality there.
LESLEY KATZEN: I
like that especially,
because I think about
my personal relationship
with my mother, and I
have multiple mother
figures in my life too.
But it was a contentious one.
I related to her essay and
then a couple of other essays
in the book.
And I thought to
myself, you know,
this is a mother who
really is a psychologist.
She's doing all of
the right things,
but still realizes
in this, again,
through the prism of this
mother-daughter relationship
and mythology, realizes that
the daughter has to go off and--
MICHELE FILGATE: Yes.
LESLEY KATZEN:
--identify herself.
And that was a
difficult one for me
to read, just knowing
that that's something
that has to happen, you know?
MICHELE FILGATE: It does.
It does.
LESLEY KATZEN: It's
a natural process.
I guess I should feel
better about that.
So I have a couple just like
last questions to wrap up,
and then we'll take
questions from the audience
and then do a signing.
Why do you think--
a lot of these stories
are about mothers
having secrets and
these secrets only
being revealed because
of something catastrophic
or upon their deathbed.
And why do you think that
mothers have so many secrets?
MICHELE FILGATE: Because
most humans have secrets.
LESLEY KATZEN:
That's true, yeah.
I'll give you that.
MICHELE FILGATE: I'm glad
you brought that up, though,
because I think there are
some great essays in here
that deal with that.
In particular, Dylan
Landis writes about
after her mother died,
trying to imagine
her mother's potential romantic
relationship with a very
famous painter.
And she enters the
imaginative realm of, like,
actually going there
and trying to write
about what it would
have been like
if her mom did have this
romantic relationship
with Haywood Bill Rivers.
And then there's a piece
by Julianna Baggott
that's really funny about her
mom telling her everything.
So not keeping secrets
but telling her--
she was the person that her
mother confessed everything to
and what that means to
carry all of that around.
LESLEY KATZEN: It's heavy.
MICHELE FILGATE:
But yeah, secrets.
I mean, all of us have them.
So of course, mothers have them.
I think it's just
a primal thing of--
LESLEY KATZEN:
Protection, love, secrets.
MICHELE FILGATE: Yes.
Yeah.
LESLEY KATZEN: Trying
to protect children
from the realities of life.
MICHELE FILGATE: Of course.
Well, that's the other thing is
not revealing your full selves
to your children.
Not showing that you
are fallible, right?
LESLEY KATZEN: Was
it Dylan Landis--
is that her name-- that was
one of my favorites as well.
MICHELE FILGATE: Yeah.
LESLEY KATZEN: It
was a fascinating--
MICHELE FILGATE: It's so good.
LESLEY KATZEN: 16 Moneta--
MICHELE FILGATE: 16 Moneta Lane.
LESLEY KATZEN: So good.
MICHELE FILGATE: Yeah.
That's the one
about the painter.
LESLEY KATZEN: Yeah.
MICHELE FILGATE:
It's really good.
LESLEY KATZEN: OK.
So we talked a little
bit about Mother's Day,
and this will be
my last question.
What would you say to somebody
who hasn't read the book yet
but was thinking about giving
it as a Mother's Day gift?
MICHELE FILGATE: I
would say that it
makes the perfect Mother's
Day gift, because it's not
overly sentimental.
But it is really-- like, there
is a lot about hope and love
in here too.
And it allows for some really
important conversations
to have.
And I've already
heard from people
who are buying it
for their children
so that they can have
these conversations that
are so difficult to have.
LESLEY KATZEN: The
first thing I thought
was I was going to get
these for my sister.
My mother, I'm not so sure.
But I might end up doing that.
So thank you so much for
answering all these questions.
It's lovely to have you here.
I love the book.
MICHELE FILGATE:
Thank you, Lesley.
And does anybody
have any questions?
AUDIENCE: So the main
reason that I'm here
is I have two daughters, a
12-year-old and a 5-year-old.
And my mom passed
away four years ago,
and she was sick for a while.
So we got to have really
good conversations
around how I treated
her growing up
and how she treated
me, how things went
growing up for us, basically.
And I guess the
thing that I'm hoping
you might have some insight,
based on your research,
how do I try to help have
even better communication
lines with my own daughters?
I don't know if
you have children
or not, but like
maybe in your research
you found information that--
I'm here for my
daughters, basically.
I'd like to foster
that relationship.
MICHELE FILGATE:
That's wonderful.
I think-- you know, I
don't have kids of my own.
But I do feel like I've immersed
myself in this very much
by editing this anthology.
And I think the
main thing is to not
be afraid to have these
difficult conversations,
anything that you feel like
you're not sure how to approach
in telling your
children or talking
about with your children, to
not let the fear stop you.
Because so often, fear is what
stop-- it paralyzes us, right?
And sometimes the most
important conversations
we can have come out
of something that we're
afraid to talk about.
So I would say to
push past that fear,
like, force yourself
to push past it,
In order to have clear
open communication.
But also, it might be good to--
even if you're not a writer--
to just write some things
down that you want to talk
to about your kids first.
That might really help
you just kind of figure
out what it is that you
are afraid to talk about
and what you want to
articulate with them.
But I-- yeah.
I don't know if that
answers your question.
No problem.
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious--
I mean, it seems like essays
like this would really
spark a lot of emotions.
And I'm curious if since
you've released this
if you've received even more
interest and reader's stories
and if you--
basically, is there a sequel?
I mean, I was just
sitting here thinking,
I can think of at least
one personal story and one
story I'm directly involved in.
And I just imagine that that's
the case with a lot of folks.
Are there plans for
a sequel or are you
getting lots of reader
interest and contribution
or more writers
wanting to be involved?
MICHELE FILGATE: Well it-- yeah.
Thank you.
That's a good question.
It just came out.
So there are no plans
for a sequel right now.
But I have been hearing
from so many people who
have read the book, strangers
who say that they can relate
to something they read
in here, that it really
made them feel less alone.
I heard from one person who
is estranged from their child
and felt like there's no
other book out there that
can help her with that.
And so that meant a lot to me.
It always means a
lot to me to hear
from anyone who's had any
kind of emotional response
to the book.
But I think, like you said,
people respond to this title.
Everyone can think
of their own stories.
So I'm hoping that
people will be encouraged
to share these stories with
their friends, their loved
ones, and keep the
conversation going
or start a conversation
to begin with.
LESLEY KATZEN: I will
say, after I read it,
I wanted to just write you,
like confessional stories of all
of my--
it did have an effect on me.
MICHELE FILGATE: Yeah.
It's really hard.
I teach creative
nonfiction, and one
of the first things
I teach my students
is to write from a place
of shame or vulnerability,
because that's often where
some of the best stories are.
And another thing,
Melissa Febos who
we were talking about before,
I was just on a panel with her.
And one of the things
she talks about
is not making yourself always,
like, the hero in whatever
you're writing about, right?
But showing yourself as
a flawed person as well,
because we all are
flawed people, right?
And so I think about that
a lot when I'm writing.
LESLEY KATZEN: All right.
Well, Michele will be
signing some books.
Thanks for coming, everyone.
MICHELE FILGATE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]